votre réaction à ces manifestations qui
ont eu lieu hier à l'appel du comité de
soutien à la famille d'adama traoré qui
fait le parallèle entre la mort de jack
floyd aux états unis et celle d'adama
traoré moi je pense que c'est très
dangereux qu'une famille ressent
douloureusement la perte de l'un des
siens je comprends parfaitement mais une
souffrance ne peut pas être là aussi
retourner contre la société
on ne peut pas faire d' équivalent entre
ce qui s'est passé aux états unis et ce
qui s'est passé en france
certains cherchent à utiliser le drame
des états unis pour leur tournée contre
la république et surtout contre nos
policiers et nos gendarmes entre celles
et ceux qui ont pour fonction d'être le
bouclier en réalité des français et je
pense qu'il faut se méfier d'un modèle
américain qu'est le modèle
communautarisme le modèle
communautariste c'est celui qui
racialise qui renvoie chacun à sa race à
ses origines à sa religion nous c'est le
modèle républicain
on est français pas parce qu'on a une
couleur de peau particulière part parce
qu'on professe une religion particulière
blême là en france mais bien sûr mais
mais ne ne disons pas que les gendarmes
ou les policiers sont rangés ces deux
corps sont rangés par le racisme c'est
absolument faux penser que la justice
française laisserait passer de tels
actes c'est aussi mal connaître la
justice française donc gardons raison et
je vois bien que derrière cela il ya
ceux qui veulent organiser la
convergence des luttes
on l'a déjà vu au moment dé gilet jaune
y compris avec ceux et celles qui
prétendent soutenir cette cause en
détournant justement cette mort
vraisemblablement accidentelle donc je
pense que c'est inacceptable et ça ne
peut être que des ferments de violences
en france donc je crois qu'il faut
raison garder il faut prendre du recul
de la hauteur